when you think about all the pornography
out there that's available online these
days and there's all kinds of stuff
there much of it for free how do you
guys compete how do you distinguish
yourself from everything else available
well qualities were important today and
I think people become a much more
selective but hush has grown steadily
for 40 years and not because of the
magazine but because of diversification
we've got into casino gaming broadcast
television retail we have huge internet
presence and this diversification I
think makes a company much more
appealing than it would have been say 20
years ago we are after all the largest
adult entertainment company in the world
by four were the number one content
provider for cable and satellite
television around the world we're going
to 67 different countries so we're not
just a magazine where a lot of people
tend to think that that's the essence of
the company but it's really not but
Larry what's the sales pitch if you do
IPO you're more than a magazine you are
a TV network but you're an Internet
channel and there's so much free
pornography on the internet what are
people going to buy into if you do go
public yeah but these people that are
putting all this free porn are free on
the internet
they're just desperate you know they're
they're trying to squeeze the profit out
this is going to this is going to
disappear we see it how we've seen it
happening and pornography that's free
online is going to disappear yeah yeah
well it will disappear because the
consumers are people that enjoy
pornography
well but the thing about it is people
like quality and now to usefully
pornography is something that men watch
too long now couples are watching it
together
I mean the country needs to wake up and
realize that let me ask you about
Playboy I in your view what did playboy
do wrong and how do you make sure that
you don't make similar mistakes Wow I
know if and I think I know what
motivates you I I think he he always
wrapped is pornography and social
redeeming articles you know the on that
quest for respectability but still yet
he was always in the pornography
business and I think he was very much
embarrassed by that I mean he would have
preferred to have been a publisher of
Time magazine rather than the public
sort of playboy me I don't have any
pretensions I know what I do I like what
I do all right Larry you know them and
you are let's say you go out and you
raise five hundred million bucks what
specifically are you going to do with
that money
we'll probably expand both gaming and
broadcast those are almost palpable
almost palpable and it is in the last
two years we required to broadcast
companies Safa media and london and new
frontier in boulder colorado and we're
getting a 35 percent return on our
investment and those companies so
broadcasters very good for us casino
gaming gaming stuff I mean we've seen a
lot of casino companies really struggle
in this environment especially when you
can pretty much game wherever you want
these days
yeah where I want we're having a record
year at our casino I agree with you on
one thing and expanding in the casino
gaming business you have to be more
geographically conscious than you were
before because a lot of states have now
legalized gaming so
competition can be much more fierce in
those areas it's not just no well then
if you can raise this kind of money
would you potentially look to buy one of
these distressed properties in Atlantic
City it seems there's a new one on the
Block every day I stay as far away from
Atlantic City as I can get to low end
yeah you're about quality right but you
mentioned you mentioned the importance
of quality and we know how much is
available online right now you mentioned
that you know you have really made an
effort to attain respectability to a
certain extent isn't that what you're
also doing though Larry by saying that
yours is a quality product versus
everything else that's out there yeah
quality smut you know that's right we do
what we do we pride ourselves in the
quality all right then what's the timing
the IPO market is very very hot right
now
do you want to get this done in the next
12 months we're exploring it now it
looks really good
we don't have to go public we want to
see if the numbers make sense so you
could raise it in the private markets
what we know we're not long we've got a
lot of cash on hand right now and
we still learn a position to call the
shots if we if our if our underwriter to
happen that will probably do it you know
there's been a huge uptick in the number
of socially conscious funds out there in
the last couple of years Larry are you
concerned that some people will say you
know what I'm not going near this just
because of what this company represents
and what it does yeah there'll be that
but they'll also be the guy that we help
make it through puberty when we first
started I saw that well like I own a few
shares of stock so one offsets the other
I think